hi everyone welcome to our homeroom
livestream I'm very excited about the
conversation we're going to have in a
few minutes but before that I will give
my standard announcement a reminder that
Khan Academy is a not-for-profit
organization with a mission of providing
free world-class education for anyone
anywhere and we only exist because of
philanthropic donations from folks like
yourself so if you're in position to do
so please think about donating I want to
give a special shout out to several
corporations that have stepped up when
they appreciated that Khan Academy was
running an in deficit even before the
copic crisis and our costs only went up
our server cost we wanted to accelerate
a whole series of programs and so
they've helped us close our definitely
we still have one so we still need your
help but it's been a huge a huge support
Novartis who we're going to talk to
Avastin our semen in a few seconds is
one of those supporters Bank for America
google.org AT&T and fastly so thanks to
all of them and I met our many other
film profit and corporate supporters and
any of you who have donated or even I
guess thought have thought about
donating so with that I'm very excited
to introduce now seaman mask good to be
here
Oregon thanks for having a great great
to be here so it's really an honor I
think as you know my family as you said
Khan Academy for four years is huge part
of our family in many ways and we're
honored as Novartis bill to support your
efforts no no and we're honored that
y'all are working with this it's funny
when I when I was doing the oak but you
know what light research I do before
this I realized that we are the exact
same age and that kind of created a bit
of an existential moment in me because
you run a large multinational like
hundred thousand plus person
organization and you know I hang out in
a walk-in closet making videos it kind
of made me maybe ponder my life but
there's been no not at all you touched
hundreds of billions of children all
around the roses extraordinary work but
I'd love to hear you know one of the
things that we like to do and you know I
encourage anyone who's watching on
YouTube or Facebook to start asking
questions about really anything but I
think what we do what I
especially cuz there's a lot of young
people watching is just understand how
do you become well first what is what
you know what does Novartis to do I
think many people know it's one of the
largest pharmaceutical companies in the
world but also and what's its focus but
I also I'd like to understand how you
ended up here so maybe to start with you
know just just make sure everyone
understands what Novartis does and what
its focus is and then I'd love to go
into your background yeah absolutely so
Novartis is about a 250 year old company
beginning in the world dying making in
the 1700s chemicals and 1800's
pharmaceuticals in the 1900 today we're
one of the the biggest companies in the
world one of the two or three largest
makers of medicines in the world we make
about on the order of 800 we reach about
800 million patients a year with our
medicines we've produced about 70
billion doses of year of Medicine in
about 150 countries everything ranging
from medicines to tackle heart disease
and lung disease and cancer all the way
to malaria and leprosy medicines but
also very high-end technologies like
keen therapies and cell therapies but
also the second largest manufacturer of
generic medicines in the world so a big
big remit big a big goal to impact
public health and as a public health
physician is really a dream job to have
this half of this opportunity as for
myself my parents were Indian immigrants
they came to the u.s. in the late 60s
night and early 1970s I grew up in
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania
where I went to some wonderful public
schools there and then later in southern
New Jersey and so very grateful for the
incredible education and very dedicated
amazing parents that I had I went to the
University of Chicago study biology went
to Harvard Medical School studied
medicine did a lot of work in developing
countries my passion in public health is
in Africa I'm working with F and Africa
but also in Peru
India and a few other locations but
through it kind of twists and turns I
ended up wanting to pursue the private
sector approach to impacting health of a
global scale was very interested in the
science of developing drugs and
medicines and how that could have a big
impact and so I went to novo came to
Novartis in 2005 spent most of my career
developing vaccines and drugs I'm a
member of the National Academy of
Medicine in the United States because of
the work I've done developing drugs and
vaccines and that led from one thing or
another to to me as somehow being the
CEO of this company as a physician
scientist who always just had a big
dream to impact the public health of the
world no thanks for that there's a lot
there I'm assuming most people have
heard of Novartis but you know just the
numbers that you just said we're kind of
mind-boggling I mean it's probably safe
to say maybe everyone watching or at
least a close relative of everyone
watching is probably in some way shape
or form taking you know some type of
medication hopefully being helped by
some type of medication that Benson
Novartis drug so that's incredible
incredible reach one you know one
question and a shout there's a question
from YouTube
anam Khan no relation as far as I'm
aware how did you know what what path or
what career was best for you how did you
know it was your passion because you
started as a what the medical school you
are a physician did it somebody to swish
it first you thought you're going to be
a practicing physician but then you
thought hey what if I can help develop
drugs or help scale therapies whatever I
think my mother is still wondering when
I'll become a cardiologist but I think
she sees federally as that has moved on
from from that discussion yeah I don't
exactly know people often ask me and
actually just recently completely
reading a great book by David Epstein
called Grange and it talks about how in
the end building broad ranges of
experience all under discover where your
best best fit is so I think for probably
10 years I did my medical studies I had
every intention of becoming a physician
I worked at the World Health
Organization worked quite a bit in
public health in Africa some great
leaders took the plunge into the private
sector without No
where we go I would say there were many
twists and turns and many moments I
would have thought this was not a good
decision but then I ended up actually in
the world of vaccines and I loved the
vaccines I loved developing new vaccines
for children and had the opportunity to
work on a number of extraordinary
vaccines and when again one thing one
thing led to another
yeah I think the book talks about it
anything is worth remembering in the
world of Education we want to build
broad minds because the world is complex
and I think building more range in
yourself from the disciplines you learn
how you can solve problems how you can
think is mobile ultimately make you
successful I think Khan Academy builds
that in people and a question I think
there's a kind of a I guess a very blunt
or funny version of the question I was
going to ask someone YouTube AZ asks
well they do how did you take over the
company which I don't think you've
received your job as
but but I guess I'll take a different
version of it what do you think work you
know when I was a kid and I saw someone
become a CEO of a multinational
organization like the party and I'd be
like how did they do that you know
there's a lot of smart people in the
world you know there's hundreds of
thousands of yeah I think Novartis you
have a hundred thousand something
employees what do you think it was about
you and and you know either it was
opportunities you got you know
serendipity and and things that you
actively did that that kind of got you
on that path yeah I'd say couple things
I get I give tremendous credit to my
parents and my wife the three of them
with Jones only not beer at this at this
moment but you know I think it was a
mixture of being able to understand the
science of medicines and having a deep
understanding of human biology and
science combined with having learned how
to translate that into business and
numbers and financials and how does that
translate into business well they didn't
really be able to speak multiple
languages speak the language of science
and speak the language of business but I
think the third element in it came back
to my education at the University of
Chicago where I was educated in the
great books was the kind of deeper
understanding of
values and mission and trying to until
that in an organization and I think that
combination I think when I was named CEO
I was not the traditional choice I think
our board took a huge Hansen in making
me a CEO there was a lot more
traditional choices one could take than
taking a physician scientists who mostly
work on developing drugs and vaccines I
think I'm I'm not mistaken I'm only of
one of maybe a handful in the whole
biopharmaceutical industry who comes
from the more of the R&D background but
I think it was that mix and having that
ability across those different
disciplines and having a kind of very
humanitarian approach or view and we
have a long journey to get there to
actually realize that that that was I
think the kind of key elements yeah and
given obviously in the virus itself the
major forms of recovery and but your
background as a physician you you've
helped develop vaccines
the obvious question you could imagine a
lot of questions coming in on social
media about that Judy Lenihan when will
a vaccine for Kovan 19 become available
and what unanticipated roadblocks on my
plate and then me ron arad from facebook
is asking if if and when it gets
developed how long does it take for mass
production and availability what's your
view on that I don't know if Novartis is
explicitly doing activity there but I'm
sure you also have a general view of
what's going on at the ecosystem yeah
you know I spent nine years eight nine
years developing vaccines and working
hard in that space we ultimately sold
our Mexican business so we're not in the
world of vaccines right now but I can
offer the perspective more of somebody
who knows the space extremely well I
think it's very important to understand
what it takes to develop a vaccine and
how different a vaccine is from a drug
in the case of a drug we know a patient
has a disease and we're treating the
disease so the so called risk benefit
equation is highly favored towards the
drug because we know the patient is ill
in the case of a vaccine we're ionizing
somebody who's otherwise healthy so the
bar for safety is extremely high and the
bar for what the benefit of the of the
medicine of the vaccine is is all
so extremely high the FDA recently put
out guidance which actually was very
much in line with what I expected the
FDA said they expect studies to be very
large and well controlled and said the
studies should likely have thousands if
not tens of thousands of patients they
expected a vaccine to have 50% efficacy
at least and they expected at minimum
six months of follow-up for the patients
who are in the trial and longer if there
was potentially a new technology that's
being used all of that comes together
and I've been one of the people
consistently said that I mean being
realistic given that you know any VEX
any drug you put into the clinic any
vaccine you put in the clinic because
somewhere between a one and a best-case
ten percent chance of making it so if we
put in a hundred we public will get one
if we really understand what we're doing
if we put in ten we'll get one really
effective vaccine or drug that's just
the historical odds in our in our in our
sector and then you combine that with
what the FDA just talked about if
anything it's realistic to expect a
broadly available vaccine not before
towards the latter part of next year now
could there be an upside case could
everything work perfectly of course and
I understand that's a lot of where the
discussion is but it's important also to
understand why we want a very safe
vaccine and why it's so important in my
mind to maintain the public trust
probably over the last hundred years
vaccines sanitation and a handful of
medicines have led to the remarkable
gains and life expectancy where people
on average in 1900 lived to about 30
years of age and today depending on
where you are in the world at 80 to 90
years of age and what we don't want to
do is undermine that belief in vaccines
it's so fundamentally important for a
public health system and I mean there's
there's several really powerful things
you said I mean one I thought that was a
really interesting way to compare normal
pharmaceutical drugs with a vaccine as
you mentioned in the dressing for a
regular drug development someone has a
disease may be a very serious disease so
you know they have it and so you just
have to see hey is the benefit of the
drug even probabilistically better than
the side-effects or the risk but a
vaccine it's a healthy person and the
side effects and the negative are you
know these things you have to look over
thousands of people because even a small
negative is not so good because you're
giving it to healthy people and you also
said that the expectation is probably
end of calendar next calendar year so
end of 2021 is your best guess it's my
guess it's just one person's guess as
you know there are a lot of opinions out
there but I mean I think that would be
that would be remarkable to have a brand
new virus show up and to have the
vaccine out the door
within two years is really an
unprecedented and it would not have
happened as far as I know before in most
cases impending mix we've generally had
influenza pandemic so we've known how to
manufacture influenza vaccines it's
about the 1950s at scale very
established technology the only thing
we're changing is the type of virus
we're not changing the manufacturing
platform we're not changing the nature
of the immune response
now with kovat we don't know what kind
of immune response we need we're trying
to use very new technology platforms
that have never been used in a large
scale to navigate all that complexity
within two years would be would be
pretty pretty remarkable yeah so you're
you're saying is kind of a fairly
bullish prediction to get endeth because
it at least you know when you watch the
news and and even if you hear you know
government governments around the world
it seems like the other people are
hopeful for three months or four months
or you know by January but it sounds you
know it sounds like we should we should
probably set our expectations it would
be a good outcome if we have a vaccine
by you know November December of 2021 I
would say yes but you know that's not
that's not necessarily what I
understandably what people are you're
interested in why there's hope and
improv you could find a vaccine that you
could use with certain populations first
responders fast service it's important
to understand what's required from the
data and the science and the science and
the data have to demonstrate you're not
going to cause harm
to patients who received are people who
receive the vaccine and then you ever
have a reasonable belief of strong
strong ethic you see yeah I spent a lot
of time developing pediatric vaccines as
a simple thing like a high fever as an
example if you have a high fever
in a recent in some significant rate in
20-30 percent of children who receive
your vaccine you quit and if you give
that vaccine to tens of millions or
hundreds of millions of people you
suddenly have lots of people showing up
in the emergency room with fever related
to the vaccine which then leads to all
other adverse consequences for the
system so it's important we ensure that
we have a vaccine we really believe in
from an efficacy and safety standpoint
and I think experts in vaccines probably
generally have that kind of perspective
yeah and and this to make sure
everyone's on the same page you're the
whole principle of immunization is to
kind of inject something into your
system that you can build your own
immune response so that if the real
thing shows up so to speak it's it's
ready and you know these there's these
notions of antibodies where students can
learn about on Khan Academy which are
kind of like like tags for certain
foreign substances that your body
doesn't want and once things are tagged
then your immune system can go and clean
up that stuff kill that stuff and so you
want those tags those antibodies it is
how is the vaccine developed is it is
essentially you get antibody observe
antibodies and people who already have
the virus it's Bo covet and you you take
some of those you just inject them in
someone else do you kind of denature
them a little bit but but the proteins
are still there how does that work
there's a few things you can do baby
what you just referred to cell is so
called 2-minute convalescence you know
so these are patients who have had the
disease develop antibody to take the
antibodies from those patients you give
it to patients affected by koban and you
hope that transferring the antibodies
can help there's been mixed results so
far with that there's a lot of
complexity and really ensuring you have
an adequate so [ __ ] dose of the
antibody so we'll have to see if that
bears out but that's of course not a
scalable solution so then the question
is
how do you give components of the
coronavirus code in nineteen to a human
to generate a very robust immune
response an immune response that has the
new characteristics one that it has a
high enough level of antibodies as you
mentioned that can prevent hopefully the
the disease from taking hold in a person
and hopefully also elicit what's called
immune memory so immune memory is the
immune system as the ability to store
cells memory T cells which can then come
back
if the infection were to happen at a
later point in time this allows for the
vaccine to protect over a long period of
time now right now there's a number of
different vaccine technologies that are
being used to try to solve this problem
one is giving RNA and so for the
students listening you know DMA goes to
RNA goes to protein see the idea that
yours if you give patients RNA the cells
in the body will turn that RNA into the
coated surface protein so the one of the
proteins on the surface of the virus and
then the immune response will develop
other approaches use DNA and a similar
sort of idea can you get the cells to
produce the COBIT particle the reason DN
RNA or the first vaccine in the clinic
is they were very easy they're much
easier to do than isolating the actual
parts of the virus so you have DNA and
RNA vaccines another approach used by
Oxford University is to actually have a
what's called an attenuated virus and
this gives a monkey adenovirus you
weaken that virus if it doesn't cause
infection in humans no illness but
instead that virus is going to express
portions of the kovin 19 virus and again
you hopefully create the immune response
so that's a attenuated virus based
approach and then and I'm just trying to
simplify from a complex field the other
rights are both up subunit virus where
you actually take the proteins from Koba
19 so you take the surface proteins and
you combine it with an another thing
called an adjuvant which really boosts
spots and you hope that that will this
a strong immune response this subunit
based approach is largely what we have
for many of the vaccines people are used
to getting or the attenuated virus based
based approach other approaches are you
could try to weaken the cope in nineteen
Maris itself and provide so all of these
different things are being approached
but the idea of can we elicit a high
antibody titer can meet create memory
and importantly can we do this in a very
very very safe way right make sure I
understand so there's at the end of the
day you want to have essentially a
low-risk either version or cousin
version of the virus or a piece of the
virus essentially of a protein that your
immune system can then learn to
recognize with antibodies and and the
memory t-cells and all the rest at end
and there's you can do that by I mean
you wouldn't insert like an entire RNA
of covin with the or it would be part of
the RNA that would produce some of the
proteins yeah so really really typically
a certain part of the RNA usually a
coding RNA for one of the proteins it
turns out once RNA gets beyond a certain
size it's very hard to give it in the
body and have it be stable long enough
to get to the various cells is that it
and so your yours and what what's kind
of the worst case I mean not to scare
folks and I know this isn't like your
you know this isn't the focus of
Novartis but I can imagine there's a ton
of questions that are coming in for how
long do you think this will last aleena
on youtube is asking I mean I'm just
curious your views well I think a
broader perspective you know what's been
remarkable to me is the scale of the
medical response moon you look at it
right now we have most of 500 vaccines
and drugs assessment I think close to
5,000 clinical trials in one stage or
another over 10,000 publications so just
like we saw an exponential increase in
the virus we've seen an exponential
increase in the response we already know
and I think it's underestimate how
remarkable it is we've already
discovered one drug called REM best of
year which is
viral drug one steroid that the UK has
now identified that already can improve
patients course with coronavirus I think
when many more of these trials read out
of drugs that are being studied we have
I think twelve drugs being studied right
now you're gonna get a collection of
drugs that can enable you to reduce the
severity of this disease and also
medical practices learning so fast so
that will hopefully give us some time
then I expect the next hopefully
effective therapies will be so-called
antibody therapies so rather than
helping having the immune system
generate a response you can provide
patients who get coded nineteen with
antibodies that can hopefully target
those if number of company is working on
that and all of that I hope will and I
believe and maybe I'm an optimist as a
physician scientist drug developer that
all of that will help us really
attenuate and mitigate the overall
burden of this pandemic and that will
buy us time to hopefully get the the
right vaccine it is worth noting we
never have I've still yet to develop a
successful vaccine of HIV which is an
ongoing pandemic that started in the
early 1980s
there are many viruses which I worked
for years on to try to develop the
viruses for something called
RSV which causes a respiratory illness
around the world regularly another drug
another virus called cytomegalovirus
there's a range of viruses that we've
been working on for decades and we were
never able to figure out how to generate
that strong immune response that we've
been talking about and that's just a
dose of realism we have to do to real to
live with and it helped the drug
development and vaccine development it's
not a sure thing yeah so the hope is you
know the vaccine might take a year might
take eighteen months might take two
years but hopefully we get more REM
deaths of years or that steroid type
treatments or other things that make it
less scary could open things up I mean
it when you look at the the general
impact on the ecosystem you know this
question from YouTube
Ariana Christophe Dulles
you know how do you think the pandemic
will affect the long-term future of the
pharmaceutical industry I do you think
sharing knowledge and science it will be
more open with in the industry and I'll
add you know are there just
manufacturing things that you know we're
building capacity to do in the future
that we'll just have a more rapid
response how are you thinking about that
what do you think yeah the things are
too - for our second question I think
you know right now that the level of
collaboration has been unprecedented i
co-chair an effort with bill gates and
the gates foundation called the gage
COBIT accelerator there we have 15 GE
o--'s really sharing compounds of drug
potential drug libraries sharing
manufacturing capacity there's two other
big collaborations also running one by
the National Institutes of Health
another informal collaboration so
there's been a pretty remarkable amount
of collaboration in the industry and I
think what we're learning from this is
there are areas in what we call the
so-called pre-competitive space that I
think can be a really powerful way to
accelerate maybe in the future
discoveries for cancer or heart disease
where if there's something like for
instance one of the things we
collaborate on is how do you get a good
animal assay for Cogan
so that you know a drug might work in
covent this sounds obvious but it's
really complicated and the more we can
share our knowledge then that were good
at it what is it what is an animal at a
so then I say so what we wanted to use
before we go into humans we want to
figure out is it drug active against
Koba 90 so we have to take cells from a
animal or a human on what works best and
when we in fact them with komen and we
try to treat the cells with the drug to
see if the drug is active it turns out
you can get lots of false positives with
this and how translatable is this into
humans and it seems like such a simple
thing but we've seen amazing lots of
complexity which then could lead you to
spend a lot of time on drugs that
probably don't make sense to spend time
on or chase drugs that should have been
killed in the development process so
that's one example simple example of
where we're learning me to cooperate a
much more main battery capacity is
another so there's there's a lot of ways
I think we're learning we can
collaborate now I think for future
pandemics
Jenny was part of the question I had the
opportunity to lead Novartis response to
the 2009 swine flu endemic there
Novartis developed vaccines back then we
developed four vaccines within six
months but that was influenza as I
mentioned we could leverage existing
technologies and we were able to produce
over 500 million doses of vaccines and
Kanab didn't spurt for the world very
quickly and it's interesting we know
what's required I think to really manage
pandemics first there's a series of
locations around the world which are
well understood where we know animals
and humans interact and there's the
possibility for viruses to move to
animals and humans they called zoonotic
hotspots they're well mapped and we can
really serve a little surveillance on
these sites if we make the relevant
investment then we need to have a lot of
transparency to rapidly know when
something has jumped in to humans so
that we don't lose time then we need to
other things we need warm capacity we
call it warm
it's a ready capacity for vaccine and
drug production that could be rapidly
scaled up that's one of the challenges
right now is we're trying to find enough
manufacturing capacity and we need
public health systems that are prepared
for these kind of very rare high-risk
events and that's hard we have to store
my personal protective equipment and
other things for something that may
never come but when it does conduct you
were ready you have stock balls ready
and you can rapidly deploy them these
were the findings I think after SARS
through the findings that there's wine
flu I suspect these will be the findings
after this mr. Penniman
you know that's super valuable and you
know what we're having these interesting
conversations I completely lose track of
time I realized we're already out of
time
well I mean any any follow you know
finishing thoughts where you know
there's a bunch of questions about young
people who are interested in career
tracks you know entering into the
pharmaceutical industry obviously y'all
support for Khan Academy is in that
spirit of how do we you know have more
people being able to enter this clearly
very important industry in the world any
any finishing I guess advice for young
people thinking about careers and in
pharmaceuticals or biotech
yeah I think the future in our in our
industry like many industries is going
to be continuing to marry different
sectors together so I think drug
discovery today is not going to do with
drug discovery is tomorrow I would
encourage all of the the students
listening to learn how to marry data
science and technology with biology and
chemistry because so much now of our
work is shifting in that direction how
can you leverage technology to really
speed up a lot of these a lot of these
efforts I was saying build-up also as I
said before your range of understanding
across different disciplines because you
don't know where the world will take you
I never wanted to be the CEO yet and so
I think building range in yourself can
help and that includes I'm a big
believer in books and philosophy and
starting all of those things can can
really matter and then maybe my last
time I saw I just wanted to add is I you
know I believe in this moment in time
where we want to build a more equal
society but we tackle topics like
structural inequalities and the problem
of race in the United States
I think Academy has a remarkable role to
play
we know fundamentally the educational
system can be empowered by great
technology like Khan Academy so I
learned that I read a book called savage
inequalities in 1994 talking about the
inequities and educational systems the
United States I firmly believe Khan
Academy helps tackle that so we're proud
to be a supporter and look forward to
the collaboration appreciate that and
obviously we agree well thanks thanks so
much for taking time out I'm sure you
know I can only imagine how busy you are
so this really means a lot thank you for
your support and really I mean that rich
why aren't you on like the news channels
explaining about vaccines cuz I feel
like we're not getting that level of
that so someone needs to give you a
policy at the top yeah maybe yeah I
think maybe I'm too realistic you're
saying things they don't wanna hear well
well thanks thanks so much Matt and I
hope we get a chance to do this again
this is a real treat absolutely
triggers on the bigger room for
listening thank you
well everyone you know I just a someone
asked what what do I learn from these
live streams or what have I learned I
think that's just another good example
where you know on a book level and
obviously have taught on Khan Academy
things about immunology and antibodies
and T cells and but you know just
talking to someone who's a real
practitioner in the field who's worked
on vaccines who runs one of the largest
pharmaceutical companies in the world
you know you just learn a whole new
level of what's going on in the world so
hopefully you enjoy that as much as I
did I mean you know there's something to
ponder if this whole pandemic goes a
little bit longer than we might have
expected but hopefully you enjoyed that
I look forward to I don't repeat it
tomorrow the day after I need to look at
my schedule I'm I live my life hour to
hour I will see you all later this week
at the homeroom do you do stay safe and
healthy